Tianran: From calorie
counts to portion sizes,
we wanted to find all the differences
between Domino's in China and in the US.
This is "Food Wars."
Here in China, Domino's
comes in three sizes:
the 7-inch small, which is
only available for two pizzas,
the fruit deluxe and the cocoa brownie,
hand-tossed only;
the 9-inch regular; and the 12-inch large.
In the US, our Domino's
pizzas come in four sizes:
small, 10-inch; medium, 12-inch;
large, 14-inch;
and the XL, 16 inches.
No, there's nothing on your screen.
The pizza is in fact that greasy.
We have three types of crust,
pan crust, hand-tossed,
and the thin crust,
and eight different crust
options, including stuffed crusts,
which are only available
outside of the US.
The UK has them. We have them.
Sweet-potato-stuffed crust.
You see that?
The orangey bit in there.
That's pretty good, actually.
It reminds me a little bit of a mooncake
in that it's sweet and savory.
Stuffed sausage crust.
Just a little sausage
peeking out of the hole.
Boletus crust. And
basically it's a mushroom.
It's a variety of mushroom,
of which there are many different species.
They're actually poisonous,
so you need to cook them properly.
If they're undercooked, they
will cause hallucinations.
The mushroom seller I met,
her husband actually
was poisoned four times,
and once he saw a bunch of
skulls either side of him.
Once he saw a mountain of gold.
One other time he just beats up a fridge,
and the last time he slept for three days.
It just tastes like wet mushroom.
Actually, we do have mushrooms
that make you hallucinate
in the US as well,
although you can't get them at Domino's.
Salted-egg-yolk-stuffed crust.
It's recommended that this is
paired with the chicken pizza,
so you basically have the
whole family in there.
That is delicious.
It tastes like a million
calories. Such a guilty pleasure.
Mm-hmm.
The meat-floss-stuffed crust.
It's not the most appetizing name, is it?
It looks a little bit like lint,
but it tastes like bacon cotton candy.
Usually it's made of pork,
but you can also get it as
beef or chicken or fish.
I don't think it quite works in crust
when crust is already so dry.
We also have something
called the double decker thin
and the double decker thick.
Correct me if I'm wrong.
I think this is actually the
double decadence from the UK.
I mean, it is pretty
much a pizza sandwich.
US Domino's, we have five
different dough varieties.
A better way of saying that is
five different crust options.
Dough varieties, yeah, same thing.
Anyway, first one down here
is a gluten-free crust,
and I want to note that it
only comes in the small,
because from Domino's perspective,
if you want gluten-free pizza,
you're eating it by yourself.
Next is the hand-tossed, kind
of the classic style, right?
Everyone's seen the hand-tossed.
To me, it's the default setting.
After that, this is the
crunchy thin, cut into squares.
That's a tavern cut, for
all you in the Midwest.
Another crust/dough variety is the pan.
This is a thick boy.
Only comes in a medium.
And, of course, the last
one is the Brooklyn style,
which you can only get in
the large or the extra large,
and it's thin and also has
these really big slices.
I can't tell. That's eight slices, right?
No, six slices, right?
So, it should be eight.
I don't know. Can someone in post
increase the contrast on that
to maybe make the lines
a little more obvious?
Our Domino's largest pizza
has a diameter of 12 inches,
or 30.5 centimeters,
and an area of
730.6 centimeters squared
and costs 88 yuan, or 12.81 USD.
Breaking that down, our pizza is 0.11 yuan
per square centimeter.
Take our large 14-inch, or
35.56-centimeter, pizza,
with an area of 993.1 square centimeters.
That's 0.15 cents per square centimeter,
or 0.96 yuan.
That means our US Domino's
pizza per square inch
is roughly 12.5% cheaper than in China.
Our Domino's categorizes their
pizzas into three groups,
indulgent, classic, and value.
Let's take a look at the indulgent first.
French-style liver mousse ham pizza.
I'm not even sure what a liver mousse is.
I assume it's meant to be foie gras.
It smells like foie gras.
Oh, but it is weird with pizza, man.
No, that should not be eaten with pizza.
That is super weird.
Why?
Mm, no.
Let's grab some New Zealand lamb.
It may be New Zealand lamb,
but they've used a lot of cumin
and basically turned
it into a lamb skewer.
Definitely miles better after that.
The sultan durian pizza.
That is a really healthy,
big piece of durian.
Abalone and scallop indulgent pizza.
I mean, just why?
Abalone is super expensive,
and it's popular in China
because its name sounds like
"to get explosively rich,"
so you'll often find
it served at weddings,
at Chinese New Year.
Ugh.
Let's clean our palate.
We'll get some Australian/New
Zealand wagyu beef.
I'd eat the beef by itself.
I'd remove everything else.
Crayfish and chicken.
I think they've gone full NOLA here,
because the chicken are
meant to be Orlean chicken,
and then we've got them craw daddies, too.
Chicken and crawdads?
I love New Orleans food,
so yeah, I would
definitely try that pizza.
South American rib eye steak.
The burdock prawn bacon indulgent pizza.
We've got peas, we've got prawns,
we've got some cherry tomatoes.
This is the Japanese-style-eel pizza,
and on the description, it actually says,
"May contain soft bones. Eat with care."
Oh, they're very tasty, though.
Here we have the Australian/South American
grain-fed diced beef, so
they either weren't sure
where the beef was sourced from
or if they run out of beef from Australia,
they go to South America.
And over here we have a
pineapple shrimp pizza.
You know, for those of you
who hate Hawaiian pizzas,
this must be so much more triggering.
No. I think it's actually
worse than a Hawaiian.
Also in the indulgent lineup
is our regular durian pizza.
This is actually a best seller.
It costs 9 yuan less than the sultan.
Oh, yeah. No, that's great.
Mm. Oh, that's delicious.
Here we have the
okonomiyaki surf and turf.
Look at that. That's
actually pretty decent.
It's even got the furikake intact.
Look at that. These
little superthin flakes.
Mm, that's decent.
Well done. Yeah, that's pretty good.
Very meaty, too.
Bacon, meat floss, potato pizza,
and it is absolutely
blanketed in meat floss
and a gigantic potato wedge.
It's a little bit like the Hawaiian pizza,
except instead of a juicy pineapple
you have sweet
bacon-flavored cotton candy.
Mm, not sure if like.
The Domino's US menu
obviously is not as robust
as China's Domino's menu,
but there are some specialty
pizzas you can get here
that you can't get there, including these.
First one here is the
Extravagan, two capital Z's, a.
This looks like a rebranding
of what would be called
a supreme pizza here. Right?
Now, if you hate vegetables, don't worry.
You can get the same pizza
but just MeatZZa version.
We got sausage, ham,
pepperoni, possibly hamburger.
This could have been just a
sausage and pepperoni pizza,
and it probably would've tasted
the same. I'm just saying.
Philly cheesesteak.
Philadelphia, let us know in the comments
how insulted you are that the
sandwich that bears your name
is now in pizza form. And
this thing looks terrifying.
Steak, cheese. Like that.
Onion and green pepper, oh, and mushrooms.
Yeah, I mean, it's not bad.
I don't know if I want a
whole thing of this, though.
I already had just one bite,
I'm like, yeah, I got it.
It's more the novelty of, yeah,
I guess that does taste
like a Philly cheesesteak,
but also, now I gotta
eat this whole pizza.
Hm.
A Cali chicken bacon ranch,
which I'm going to go ahead and assume is,
what do you think?
Chicken, bacon, some sort of ranch.
I don't know what makes it California.
That's not bad.
Buffalo chicken.
In China, they had all
these really interesting
flavor combinations that
I'm sure someone was just
really trying to capture the
breadth of Chinese tastes.
Here, everything is like,
this exists somewhere else.
We just did a pizza form.
Case in point, Buffalo chicken.
Hey, do you like wings?
Yeah.
Do you want it in pizza form?
No.
Too bad. Buffalo chicken.
Another one here, spinach and feta.
No.
Because I just bit into
a thing of feta cheese.
No.
Another specialty pizza we
have exclusive to the US
and not in China is a
Wisconsin six-cheese,
which, assuming from the name, has,
let me go ahead and guess, six cheeses?
And they put Wisconsin on there
because Wisconsin is the cheese state.
Shout-out to Wisconsin.
On to our classic offerings,
beginning with the
salted-egg-yolk-flavored chicken,
which, as you can see, was
very welcomed by the crew.
We're already missing two pieces.
The Chinese name for this is golden sands,
which is a specific way of
cooking the salted egg yolk
so that it becomes a sort of frothy paste
that can be used to coat various things.
It's a salty, sweet umaminess.
Teriyaki beef potato pizza.
Teriyaki beef, yes.
The pizza itself is already quite starchy.
It's all carbs, and then
a potato on top of that.
It's a staple and a staple.
Most of these pizzas are sweet.
Peking duck pizza.
I'm very conflicted about this.
I like that they're representing us,
but this looks very blasphemous to me.
That actually sounds amazing.
Nope, nope, nope, nope.
Blasphemous. No.
OK, never mind.
I'd still try it, though.
Here we've got the tuna seafood deluxe.
Not that big a fan of
seafood pizza, myself.
Truffle-flavored sauce,
mushroom, and chicken pizza.
Two types of mushrooms in that pizza,
but note that the truffle
is a flavored sauce,
so that's not included as one
of the types of mushrooms.
Ah, no.
Normal pizza, yes.
Chorizo pizza.
I don't know why there's
peas on all of the pizza,
but look, I'm gonna take it
for just regular meat toppings.
Yes, chorizo, get in here!
Tastes like Bolognese sauce,
but it's OK. I can dig it.
Especially after all of this
stuff, I'll take anything.
And now our value options,
beginning with the Texas barbecue.
Now, the description says it has
Texas-style meat.
I assume it's ham.
Again, it's sweet, but here
since it's a barbecue sauce,
maybe a honey glaze, I'm OK with that.
The lychee chicken pizza.
Don't know why it's paired up like that.
This is actually a pretty
meme-errific pizza.
The name is very punny,
and it references a
middle-aged Chinese influencer
who screams at the top of his lungs,
"Aoligei!"
Which kind of just
translates to, "Come on."
Many times people have said
that I kind of look like
that guy, and it's just,
I don't know what they're talking about.
There's no resemblance whatsoever.
Aoligei!
All I taste is the lychee.
The potato bacon pizza.
This is one of Domino's
all-time bestsellers,
and the name in Chinese
actually says "American style."
I don't know, is this what
you guys eat over in yonder?
Nope.
Here we go.
Here's a taste of America.
Mm-hmm. Land of the free.
Who am I to judge?
I don't know what kind of potato wedges
Americans like to put on their pizza.
Korean-style fried chicken,
also with sesame seeds, seaweed,
marinara sauce, and
what looks like onions.
Hey, that's a winner.
Winner, winner, chicken dinner.
Veggie deluxe. Not touching it.
Over here we have something special.
These are our two smallest
pizzas, the 7-inchers.
This is the fruit deluxe.
Peach, blueberry jam,
pineapple, coconut gel.
Mm!
You know what's best?
It's actually meant to be sweet.
If I've tried one dessert pizza,
I'm going to try the other one,
the cocoa-flavored-brownie pizza
with brownie cubes and cocoa powder.
It's actually not so bad.
It reminds me a little bit
of Nutella on buttered toast.
I can dig it.
Still here.
Man, that's a lot of pizza.
We at the US Domino's have sandwiches,
specifically these seven.
Most of them are just versions of pizza
that are also in sandwich form,
first one being the Buffalo chicken.
Let's get a look in there.
The chicken, cheese, and the sauce.
The chicken habanero.
I like a habanero thing
because it has the sweet and the spicy,
pineapple and jalapeños,
together in one bite.
This one, bleh, Mediterranean veggie.
Feta cheese and spinach.
That's in the Mediterranean area, I guess.
Banana peppers, which I don't
think exist outside of the US.
Oh, the Philly cheesesteak. Ugh.
It's double depressing because, I mean,
the Philly cheesesteak is a sandwich.
It has a specific way of being made.
This is not what a Philly cheesesteak
is supposed to look
like. Why do this? Right?
Over here we got the chicken bacon ranch.
Bro, they were generous with the ranch.
Look at that.
Lots of bacon and chicken and the cheese.
Nice.
An Italian sandwich. Mamma mia.
Salami, cheese, ham, and another salami.
And, of course, what is more Italian than
banana peppers?
And the chicken Parm
sandwich, chicken Parmesan,
which is, again, an incredibly popular,
already well-established sandwich
that Domino's for some reason
felt they needed to deconstruct
and then reconstruct in a different way.
I don't want any of these.
No sandwiches here in China,
but what we do have is rib eye steak.
Waiter!
Oh, whoa!
That's a big piece of steak.
Hm.
Let's talk pasta and rice.
We have both!
Here are our pasta options.
All come with spaghetti,
or you can pay one extra
yuan to upgrade to penne.
Spag Bol. Looks decent. Smells good.
Lot of Bolognese on the pasta.
Spaghetti basil.
I'm pretty sure that's just a carbonara.
Here we've got a seafood pasta
with scallop and squid roe.
Here we've got the rice options.
Chorizo baked rice.
You've got some chorizo,
you've got some pepperoni.
Truffle-flavored baked rice
with chicken and bacon.
Not gonna touch that.
Don't like my truffles.
And just a nice wholesome curry beef rice.
Curry sauce, beef, rice.
What could go wrong?
No rice dishes in the US, but
we do have our own pastas,
four specifically.
This is the fourth Domino's "Food Wars"
that I have been a part of.
I want to again state that I
think the pastas at Domino's
are an absolute abomination.
So if you're watching from outside the US
and you think this looks
weird, you are correct.
This pasta is so weird!
Italian sausage marinara.
I mean, I can't even break
through the skin of this thing.
Come on, man.
Chicken carbonara.
Ugh.
Oh, it hurts my soul.
Ugh! Pasta primavera.
Whatever primavera means, it ain't this.
And last, chicken Alfredo. Ugh.
Both countries have wings.
In China, you can only get
your wings in orders of four,
unless you go for the wings combo.
Now, here we have four exclusive flavors.
Cantonese roast.
Sweet in a fruity sort of sweetness,
and you've got that barbecue smell.
It tastes like Chinatown.
Next we have the Orleans flavor.
Oh, it's very spicy. Wow.
Oh. Oh, my gosh.
We also have the honey and
the barbecue-flavored wings,
and I believe in the US
you just have them combined
as a honey barbecue,
but here we get an extra flavor out of it.
I'm sure some of you might have noticed
our wings look a little bit different.
A wing is made up of three parts,
the drum, the flat, and the tip.
Usually it's removed because
it doesn't have much meat,
but here in China we love fiddly food.
Basically, here in China,
we love the tip so much
that we even have an
entire dish devoted to
just the tip.
One thing I do love on the menu, though,
is the Domino's wings.
In the US, you can get wing
orders in eight, 16, or 32.
We only have four exclusive flavors,
starting down here at the hot.
Then the honey barbecue,
sweet mango habanero,
and last, the garlic Parmesan.
On the presentation,
this is especially hm,
but they are very good.
I mean, I'd still get pizza over wings,
but if you're going to get wing sides,
Domino's wings, not bad.
We also have roast skewers.
Now, these are something that
are popular street foods.
Here we've got some chicken satay skewers.
We've got beef skewers.
These also come in the lamb
version, incredibly delicious,
and also
roast sausages.
I think these are usually
what kids like to eat.
I don't usually see adults eating these.
These would be sweet sausages,
but they're very filling.
China also has seafood options,
namely our golden shrimp,
which actually look a little bit orange,
pollock bites, and regular fish bites.
Our other sides include chicken rolls.
I believe it's smoked chicken,
mayo, and egg and peas.
Those peas. Peas make it
into every single menu item
here at Domino's.
Mini hot dogs wrapped
in a very cute blanket.
It's almost like it outgrew its blanket.
Healthy salad, star-shaped hash browns,
onion rings, and potato wedges.
Both countries have garlic bread,
but ours, we do it a little differently.
Ours is stuffed with
cheese and other stuff.
For instance, this one right here,
jalapeño and bacon.
Why this over pizza?
Another one we have here
is the spinach and feta.
We have twists. We have bites.
Starting over here, we've got
the Parmesan bread twists.
Looks like it's kind of doing this,
like please don't give me diarrhea.
[toilet flushing]
Garlic bread twists.
Do you want this taking
up space in your stomach?
I don't.
Just get more pizza.
I mentioned it before. We got dips.
What are dips?
From what I can tell, just big portions
of something to dip these breads in.
First one is, oh, my good Lord.
Going to go ahead and assume
this is the five-cheese.
Look at that, Yuelei.
Look at the oil on this.
Ugh.
You know what it tastes like?
Like pizza, but without the sauce.
And not to be outdone,
looks like the cheese one,
but this one, you guessed it, has
marinara sauce.
So if you got sick of having bread
with the sauce and cheese on it,
you can just get the
sauce and cheese baked
and then the bread baked separately
and just dip them!
Who wants this instead of pizza?
I don't understand, but all right.
We have square garlic
bread and garlic bread.
I actually don't know
what the difference is
besides the shape,
but they both come with
this honey mayo dip.
I actually thought this was mustard.
I think it's mustard, mayo, and honey.
I think the bread is just
an excuse to eat this dip,
because it is actually pretty good.
We also have soups.
You can get a nice bowl
of pumpkin cream bacon,
classic borscht, or
cream of mushroom soup.
Desserts.
Unfortunately, both China
and the US have lava cakes,
so it is not exclusive,
but we have a couple things
that you can't get in China,
specifically these cinnamon bread twists
and the Domino's marbled cookie brownie.
Come on, who doesn't like brownies?
And you can tell they put a
little cookie dough in there.
It's a cookie-brownie hybrid.
And we got this icing that
you would dip in here,
and I'm not going to do it.
I've decided I'm taking a stand
against all twisted bread.
Not happening, sorry.
Here in China, our
exclusive dessert options
are limited to durian pie.
I believe this is durian.
I had a sniff.
It's durian.
You can always tell if
something is durian.
Just put your nose to it.
Pineapple pie,
and we have one of two
Portuguese egg tarts.
Drinks. In the US, you can
get Sprite, Fanta orange,
Dasani water, and Dr Pepper.
This is emblic leafflower
and coconut jelly.
I had to do quite a bit of research
to figure out what an emblic is.
Apparently it's some kind of fruit
that actually has a lot
to do with Buddhism,
but it has great cooling
and cough-relieving properties,
so this is perfect for summer
when it's too hot outside.
Oh.
It's kind of nice, but
it also kind of tastes
like I'm drinking green
perfume, if that makes sense.
It's very, very floral.
This is coconut and musk melon.
Hm.
Oh, that's tasty.
It's a little bit too
rich, so nay to that.
And this,
this is carambola and olive.
It's such a weird combination, right?
So, a carambola is this thing.
It's a star fruit, but I've
never had it as a drink.
And together with Chinese olive? OK.
Learn something new every day.
Mm. Oh, that was a pleasant surprise.
There was actually some coconut
jelly at the bottom, too,
that was very inviting.
We also just have a regular
mango and passion fruit drink.
Oh, and bottled water.
Domino's entered China in 1997,
but for about two decades, they
pretty much just floundered
and nobody really took notice of them.
It was only really in recent years
that they've become very youthful
with all sorts of wacky
flavors, as you've seen,
and because it's not
as common as McDonald's
or KFC in China, a Domino's
opening in, for example,
a tier-two, tier-three
city is big news to locals,
and a lot of people actually
post about it on social media.
"Oh, look, a Domino's
has come to our town."
It's something to be proud of.
Domino's in the US,
I feel like it's been
Domino's versus Pizza Hut,
Pizza Hut versus Domino's
since I think the '80s.
Yes, there's other
nationwide pizza chains.
Papa Johns sucked up
a lot of the attention
online for a while.
There's Little Caesars,
there's a bunch of other ones,
but it really is Domino's and Pizza Hut
have been neck and neck.
I mean, they're kind of interchangeable.
Now people watching are
going to be like, "No,
one's better than the other."
Honestly, I don't think I
could taste the difference
if you put them side by
side, but with Domino's,
as far as the reputation, you always know
you're going to get a
good pizza, a hot pizza,
it's going to be decently
priced, which is nice.
Here in China, Domino's
main rivals are, of course,
Pizza Hut, who dominates the market
with a steady 5% market share.
Next in line is a local
brand called Champion Pizza,
with 5.6% of the market share.
And third comes Domino's,
at 5.3% of the market share.
Like in the States, Domino's
China has a guarantee
to deliver your pizza within 30 minutes.
Otherwise, they will give
you all sorts of discounts.
This really sets them apart
from other pizza players here in China,
because they use their own
proprietary delivery service,
whereas most restaurants
in China use a third party
akin to something like Uber Eats.
It's also something that's become
a bit of a double-edged
sword, because people
will actively try and game
their 30-minute delivery window
by switching off corridor
lights, removing door numbers,
and just generally trying to get
their delivery drivers lost,
and about half of all of Domino's
salary payments go towards
their delivery drivers,
which shows you how big of
a delivery force they have,
which is actually kind of quite nice.
Convenience, I mean, Domino's is probably
one of the most convenient pizza chains
in the United States.
You can get a Domino's pizza,
you can get it in the app,
it's easy to use, the
pizza's at your place
in probably 30 minutes,
depending where you live.
Some would say too convenient.
The Domino's in China doesn't disclose
their nutritional information,
but based on third-party
independent research,
we found that a large
hand-tossed pepperoni pizza
has 1,466.4 calories,
64 grams of protein,
66.4 grams of fat,
155.2 grams of carbs,
and 3,257.6 milligrams
of sodium.
Our large pepperoni is
370 calories per slice,
or 2,960 for the entire pie.
Also, 299% of your daily sodium.
Oy! That's a salty pie.
Domino's China's most
calorific pizza is this,
the large salted-egg-yolk-flavored
chicken pizza
with stuffed sausage crust.
Now, one slice is 230 calories,
and the full pizza is 1,841 calories.
Our Domino's pizza with the most calories
is the Cali chicken bacon ranch.
An extra-large slice is 560 calories,
and the full pie, 3,360 calories.
Two ingredients you won't
find in Domino's in China
are potassium bromate and ractopamine.
Both have been banned for use in China.
Potassium bromate is used
as a dough conditioner,
and it's classified as
a category 2B carcinogen
by the International Agency
for Research on Cancer.
Ractopamine is FDA-approved,
and it promotes muscle-mass development,
limits fat deposition, and
reduces feed consumption.
Although it is considered
safe for human consumption,
China requires all meats
sold to be free of the drug
and never fed the product to begin with.
There is no direct link
stating ractopamine
is specifically used in
the meat at Domino's,
but on their stewardship
page under "Animal Care,"
they state, quote, "It's
important to highlight
that Domino's does not
own, raise, transport
or process the animals
used for our products.
Domino's purchases pork,
beef and poultry ingredients
from suppliers who obtain their products
from farmers and ranchers
who raise and care
for their animals in
compliance with local,
state and federal guidelines,
industry best practices
and the support of farm
and animal veterinarians."
That is a very long legalese
way of Domino's saying,
"Hey, we don't farm the meat.
We buy them from other people,
and they're saying they're
doing it the right way,
so we don't know."
I was traumatized as a kid
because I had a fish bone
stuck horizontally in my throat
and I had to go to the hospital,
and the doctor basically reached
in and just yanked it out,
and for many years I just
did not want to eat fish,
but in China, it's fish with
bones or nothing at all,
so tough luck.
You just gotta suck it up.